here now Ben Shapiro editor-in-chief of
The Daily wire calm just finished four
weeks of election specials on Fox News
Ben good to see as always thanks for
being here tonight you've been looking
at this very closely over the past few
weeks do you think that their fears are
justified well I mean certainly there's
a reason to be afraid there are some
polls that came out in battleground
districts showing that Republicans were
running basically even with Democrats in
an enormous number of battleground
districts those of course would be the
districts that were very competitive
between President Trump and Hillary
Clinton what looks that the map looks to
me as though the red areas are getting
redder and the blue areas are getting
bluer and the purple areas are getting
more purple so what that suggests is
that this is not going to be a walk in
the park for Democrats the way the
Democrats thought it was going to be
even a few weeks ago and I'm not sure
that leading into a heavily contested
midterm election you want your going
away message to be we don't like due
process with justice Cavanaugh and also
we're not really sort of Native American
with Elizabeth Warren those didn't seem
like two great takeaway messages you
know it's also interesting to me that
they are very fired up about the
electoral college and about the fact
that every state gets to send two
senators to the United States Senate and
that tells me that they're worried that
you know as they look forward in history
as they look forward it doesn't look
good for them the composition of the
country well certainly not in the Senate
and and also in the electoral college
because again states are slightly out
weighing population centers in the
electoral college Democrats is very
funny after 2016 when we kept hearing
over and over from Democrats who thought
Hillary was going to win that President
Trump needed to accept the results of
the election so far we have heard from
Democrats since 2016 that we should
change the constituency of the Senate
abolish the Supreme Court abolish the
Electoral College and abolish ice so I
get the feeling that acceptance isn't in
the cards anytime soon here all right
well you know Hillary Clinton is
obviously spending a lot of time back in
the limelight again which is raising
questions about whether or not she's
potentially even considering running
again there was one op-ed that was
arguing that she might you know that
three times might be the charm for
Hillary Clinton she also you know is
getting probably more attention than
some Democrats would like at this
juncture in the election with comments
like this let's watch this
in retrospect do you think bill should
have resigned in the wake of the Monica
whiskas can absolutely not it wasn't an
abuse of power no no there are people
who look at the incidence of the 90s and
they say a President of the United
States cannot have a consensual
relationship with an intern the power
imbalances to was an adult she was an
adult she seemed to like no mind of
questioning and I can't say I really
blame her it's pretty uncomfortable she
was an adult is her argument in the for
the pre me to experience of Bill Clinton
well I definitely am enjoying watching
the goal posts move at light speed
around the field thanks to Democrats
deciding the consent does have power
relationships attached or it doesn't
have power relationships attach perjury
is sometimes good sometimes fibbing
about sex is bad it seems to depend on
the day and mostly it depends on whom
they are defending so Hillary Clinton
making life a nightmare once again for
her Democratic colleagues who must be
wishing at this point that they could
somehow wish her into the cornfield all
right I do want to get your thought on
this because it just broke tonight this
is Michael avenatti it will now have to
pay Donald Trump president Donald
Trump's legal fees for the stormy
Daniels case which just fell apart
here's the quote from president Trump's
attorney on this he says no amount of
spin or commentary by stormy Daniels or
her lawyer mr. avenatti can truthfully
characterize today's ruling in any way
other than total victory for president
Trump and total defeat for stormy
Daniels rough couple of weeks for
Michael avenatti been well Michael
avenatti who is my entertaining front
runner for 2020 I was really looking
forward to Michael avenatti making a
play in the Democratic primaries I have
to say that at this point
Michael avenatti is as much of a good
lawyer as Elizabeth Warren as a Native
American I mean he's campaigning as
early as like this weekend in South
Carolina it will be interesting to see
and you know you did call for it I think
on this show when all when he first got
on is in saying that you really hoped he
would run for president Ben I did and I
still do because this is highly highly
entertaining stuff but again he's one
1,020 fourth of a decent lawyer because
this was not a good case to bring in the
first place and now he's been humiliated
a couple of times in three weeks 20
seconds but I just do you think that the
Harvard case will overturn affirmative
action you know I would like to see it
do so but again Harvard is a private
institution not a public institution at
the very least Harvard is wildly
hypocritical for
talking about diversity while banning
essentially Asian students ben shapiro
always a pleasure great to see you Ben
thanks a lot